[Musique]
vous
merci beaucoup de vous joindre à nous,
c'est un tel plaisir d'être ici et je
voudrais également remercier tout particulièrement
le comité d'organisation pour
avoir organisé des événements incroyables et également
amené des conférenciers de classe mondiale  pas
seulement au Togo mais dans le monde entier
, nous avons donc beaucoup d'excitation à
parler dans le discours et je
vais continuer et passer le flambeau à Jeremy en
tant que capacité de base immédiatement, les
infirmières de maternité sont les compilées croisées
l'aide d'urgence internationale
autour des estimations d'excuses varie selon la
mère de famille jusqu'à ce qu'au moins un
contrat de marché soit propre continuez la plupart des initiatives
pour moi
[Musique]
l'équipe sur DVD
une fois de plus à Zaventem essentiellement
[Musique]
alors oui alors Jenny vient de dire soda son
histoire inspirerait  lui, mais aussi dans ce
n'est pas grand
1,7 milliard de personnes dans le monde n'ont pas accès
aux services financiers,
ce qui est encore plus grand que cinq milliards de
personnes considèrent comme n'ayant pas de connaissances financières
, soit près de deux sur  trois
personnes alors qu'est-ce qui a inspiré mon histoire
bien mon histoire personnellement m'aurait-il amené
au point de croire qu'il doit y avoir
une littératie financière si personnelle a commencé
quand je n'étais qu'un jeune garçon j'avais onze
ans oui je ressemblais à un tamia
et mais j'étais  juste 11 ans et je
sais que j'étais vraiment fou à
ce sujet Je me souviens être rentré de l'école
et d'autres ont littéralement couru à l'intérieur de la
maison et juste vous savez ramasser des livres
qui parlent de finances personnelles
Je viens de trouver cet amour et puis quand
J'étais au lycée la Grande Récession
de 2008 la crise financière ce soir et
cela m'a fait creuser plus profondément, alors j'ai
fini de manière très surprenante, je finis par aller à l'
université et je me spécialise en biologie J'ai en
quelque sorte fait un changement à 180 toujours pensé
personnel  la finance personnelle comme la
littératie financière doit l'être
et même si certains collèges sont vraiment bien,
c'est un très bon test, je le fais juste
, même si ma passion est
toujours avec mon argent,
donc ma dernière année je finis par faire
c  complète ce qui est encore une fois après un
tas de euh Fester si pas me poser la
question n'est pas l'argent des étudiants c'était
comme naturel donc finit par aller à l'
école doctorale et à l'école doctorale et cela
parce qu'une réunion de maîtrise en économie financière
et littéralement le premier jour
de  cours qui m'a vraiment frappé que je
devais agir c'était un classique sur
la gestion financière et les professeurs ont
commencé à accorder des connaissances
financières inclusives c'est la crise d'une
bouée de sauvetage que personne ne connaît alors
j'ai levé la main j'ai dit quelle est une
solution quelles sont  les gens qui faisaient pour
résoudre efficacement ce problème et le
professeur quand c'était un cours de trois heures
et en tant qu'homme, monsieur était de toute façon
comme un gros morceau de moi et qui nie
dans ces cours n'a pas toujours
collé avec moi et puis un autre  chose
qui m'a toujours envoyé aussi, surtout que
je grandissais, je savais juste que parler
d'argent dans mon ménage était un
sujet très sombre, ce n'est pas que les gens
ne voulaient pas parler de mon esp  ecially
mon père en fait, chaque fois que nous parlons
d'argent, il courait en fait hors de
la pièce, donc j'ai toujours su diriger le
sujet, donc j'ai toujours pensé que l'argent
était brillant pour que vous sachiez en
avoir comme une mangue aux couleurs vives l'un des
fruits les plus populaires  dans le monde,
cela finit par devenir une entreprise qui a
démarré il y a environ trois
ans à la fin de 2016, appelée bin mango, donc
ça a été un plus et mango
comme mangue et tard dans ce voyage et
aveuglant à cela depuis plus de trois ans
maintenant, je  Je n'ai jamais pensé que ce serait faire
ça à plein temps
et vous savez cette opportunité de le faire
comme une formation pour cadres comme une sorte
de programme à Harvard et de rencontrer des
gens incroyables qui depuis que je pense que c'est
encore plus cool et vraiment humiliant
parce que le fait  que nous avons une grande
base de bénévoles dans un vaste réseau maintenant
qui s'étend à 17 pays différents
et nous avons des centaines de bénévoles
ou des centaines de supporters et c'est tellement
humiliant et cette diapositive ici est
juste un petit hommage à quelques-unes
des personnes incroyables qui nous soutiennent, nous ne sommes
tous qu'un tas de négatifs, donc de toute façon
je vais le transmettre à Jeremy,
c'est là qu'il va parler plus
spécifiquement de l'impact
[Musique]
dans la communauté freak 11 is 11
Boston est quelque chose d'une certaine tâche
impossible après l'organe d'Adrienne maintenant
notre deuxième soit au niveau national
vous savez la fonction d'accident de Césarée l'
enfer aussi laissez-moi parler est le fait
que nous pensons après avoir fait tant de choses est
aussi sur les processus  et les méthodologies
et je n'ai pas pris ce chandail à
Harvard et j'ai vraiment aidé dans un processus
appelé conception et
mise en œuvre de Smart Casa dans toute l'idée de six
étapes vous avez bosselé mon problème nous mourons vit
ce problème donc vous trouvez la cause la
cause de la cause  jusqu'à ce que vous trouviez la
cause première, vous concevez ensuite un programme
basé sur ce coût que vous
implémentez ensuite et pendant que vous
implémentez, ils testent et
affinent, cela peut toujours être
rigoureusement obtenu  mieux et ne pas répéter les choses et
échouer et c'est vraiment important si c'est en
fait vous savez que les rapières du Togo
étaient en fait notre premier projet à l'international
également aux États-Unis et cela a été un
exemple clair de toujours vous savez que nous avons
trouvé beaucoup et nous avons juste continué à travailler
sur  et travailler dessus pour être sûr qu'ils
peuvent renforcer le point unique, donc je vais juste
aller de l'avant et expliquer maintenant
qu'il y a comme un petit exemple avec une
analyse plus approfondie de la façon dont les finances qui sont du
sérum peuvent faire une grande différence donc
imaginons que je suppose que vous pouvez continuer comme ça allez-
y et fermez les yeux et les autres
ferment les yeux et je vois ces yeux
ouverts
venez sur les sous-marins supervisés subtils et donc de
toute façon imaginez simplement que vous êtes cet
incroyable auteur en herbe le foie
fonctionnera si c'est un  l'agriculture
vous avez déjà une petite petite
entreprise incroyable et ça marche et vous gagnez de l'
argent et vous devez vous développer vous
savez que vous pouvez vous développer et aller nous pouvons gagner
plus d'argent
je verrai vous savez que vous continuez à  la
banque et vous allez à la banque et vous
découvrez que vous ne pouviez pas les obtenir pourquoi
eh bien il y a de nombreuses raisons le dernier manque d'
accès un manque d'antécédents de crédit
parfois ils ne connaissent pas votre propre sentiment
votre propre secteur il y a tellement de
raisons différentes  et donc ce
type potentiel de ne jamais être exploité, il va juste
sur le robinet, donc ce que l'intérêt financier
qu'Internet inclut souvent peut
faire, c'est que vous savez fournir une éducation, vous pouvez
fournir un système de réseautage et de mentorat, mais
cela peut également diviser l'accès au capital et
cet accès de  capital pouvez-vous savoir donner
cette option ou cette capacité à vous savez
agrandir la ferme et augmenter leurs
revenus diminuer leurs dépenses parce que
vous savez qu'ils savent mieux ne pas aimer
quoi dépenser mais vous pouvez également
augmenter leurs économies et également augmenter
votre potentiel de revenus futurs  et ce qui est
vraiment puissant ici, c'est le fait que cela
a comme un effet domino, vous savez que vous
voyez l'accès à l'éducation devenir plus
pertinent, vous voyez le fait que l'
éco local  les nomies peuvent en fait gagner un
niveau de chômage parce que quand il y a
plus d'argent, c'est plus d'argent dépensé
et c'est juste ce jeu et ensuite vous
pouvez aussi le voir sur le plus grand accès à
l'eau potable et aussi à la sécurité alimentaire et
cela nous a en quelque sorte fait avancer  comme la
toute fin ici, c'est juste le fait que
c'est vraiment important de comprendre que
financièrement
l'inclusion financière n'est qu'une petite
pièce d'un grand puzzle la
pauvreté est un puzzle géant qui prend
beaucoup de pièces et financièrement dire que l'
inclusion n'est qu'une petite pièce mais c'est
une pièce très importante pourquoi, parce que c'est la
résilience des ciliés iljimae, c'est la
capacité d'absorber les adaptogènes pour absorber,
adapter et transformer et c'est ce que
c'est la perspective et nous avons tous été
là dans la vie, vous savez que vous ne recevez qu'un
coup de poing au visage
comme littéralement obtenir  messages, vous pouvez soit
décider de rester sur le terrain et simplement
abandonner, soit utiliser cette résilience
pour savoir absorber, adapter et transformer
et c'est sur quoi nous travaillons  nd je
vais aller de l'avant et passer la genèse
je suis désolé l'hypothèse de selfie avons-nous
besoin des casinos en Europe un
problème spécifique le problème manque dans l'
écologie des ressources le présentéisme la
vie est quelque chose que j'ai vu quand le
dominie protégera réellement  dissoudre
quelque chose de disparate la base d'origine de lasondra
est la sagesse clé non seulement dans la mesure où mon règne
est tout remarquez nos progrès un je
dis résoudre le problème de ce qui est
important à propos d'un facteur DC bienvenue dans
mon entreprise 1-0
venez sur un registre özkan özkan özkan
même souhait de conteneur  pour un doux
économiste, c'est que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous